happy friday my friday friends it's
practically the weekend i can already
see cat's mascara running down her face
as she facetimes me sobbing from a
brooklyn drunk tank
speaking of children as you know i hate
them
small gross touchy sticky smelly and
stupid and from what i've heard
constantly in need of food water and
shelter
they're like pets but with tuition
plus they take up all the booster seats
whenever i go to a restaurant
so we've established children are dumb
but should we be making them dumber that
seems well really dumb and the new york
times agrees in a piece that now finally
trashes extended school shutdowns when
covet erupted schools in every state
shut down quicker than disneyland after
a death on the teacups
it happened you don't remember it remote
instruction took over but then districts
started making their own choices about
opening up some resumed in person others
stay closed meanwhile i completely shut
down my wrestling class i ran in the
attic
but these differences as the times notes
allows us to compare remote learning
versus in-person teaching and the
results are in like cnn plus
remote learning the bed
according to research i had my assistant
read out loud while i was getting a
pedicure
students who attended in-person school
for nearly all of 2020 and 2021 lost 20
percent of the typical school year's
math learning
lucky for them that number means nothing
to them anymore
some of the losses stemmed from remote
learning but others from families coping
with illness and other stuff
but students who stayed home most of
that time fared way worse losing roughly
fifty percent of math learning during
that two year window roughly fifty
percent and if my high school algebra
holds up it's at least a third
so now the experts agree in-person good
remote setting bad or
maybe the so-called experts realize that
remote learning made it harder to
corrupt your child with their politics
if mommy and daddy were checking in on
the lessons maybe these numbers aren't
are meant to get your kids back in
school where they could be freely
indoctrinated
ever think of that
i just did and it really hurt my head
besides it's not the first time schools
have made bad staffing choices
[Music]
well thanks for coming in uh debra so
tell me why would you be the perfect
choice to teach in our school district
as as a polyamorous non-binary person of
privilege
i understand that no childhood is
complete without understanding how
racist you really are i i love teaching
art i have four master's degrees to
prove it the kids could help me design
the matching neck tattoos that i want to
get with all five of my partners they're
us they're sexual partners we have sex
get over it
well i'm sold welcome to che guevara
elementary
[Applause]
you should be ashamed of yourself
i never am sadly school closures really
hammered low-income students black
latino students fell far behind creating
a gap in educational inequality that
already existed and now might last for
years it's a gap that administrators
can't blame on racism although you know
they'll try we may not know the
consequences of this for years when the
jerks responsible have comfortably
retired on their massive pensions
and hopefully by then i will have left
the country with clive owen
to create that apple farm we've been
talking about
i want to call it how do you like them
apples
he keeps calling the cops
clive don't
so who does the times blame now this is
amazing are you sitting down of course
you are who watches tv standing up in
their home well they show that schools
with lots of poor students were more
likely to go remote intended to be run
by democrats or more likely to have
unionized teachers whose unions lobbied
for remote schooling must have killed
the times who admit this
their autocorrect kept changing teachers
union to sexist white men just out of
habit
but we knew this every time we said it
however they crapped on us like they
were amber heard at the macy's linens
department
it's obvious low-income students do
worse on remote because their home may
not be as conducive to actual learning
as richer families it's hard for a 14
year old to do her homework while she's
cooking eggs for her younger siblings
because mom already left for work so the
vulnerable got screwed once again by the
people who claim to be their saviors
this is something we were screaming
about but we're fox news if we say it's
bad the dems have to say it's good we
could say testosterone therapy is
harmful and next week the cast of the
view would all have handlebar mustaches
not that i would notice so was this
avoidable well school administrators
knew extended school closures were
harmful a year and a half before they
acted they gave in to teachers who
didn't want to go to work unless the
environment was 100 guaranteed covet
free we also knew that coveted spread
wasn't worse in places that reopened
versus places that remained closed yet
politicians bowed to the unions as the
times notes
quote officials said they were doing so
to protect children and especially the
most vulnerable children the effect
however was often the opposite so are
you surprised
i'm not i guess the silver lining is
that we learned something from the
pandemic that we can use
next time one hits which dr fauci
predicts will be sometime between now
and tuesday
and worse our kids will be too dumb to
remember what to do
let's welcome tonight's guest
he's the king of camp and knows how to
vamp iconic filmmaker and author of the
new book liar mouth the feel bad romance
john water
[Applause]
we pay her to be cat's best friend
kennedy on fox business kennedy
she's the only vegan who's out for blood
fox business anchor dagging mcdowell
and like a candle in the wind she's the
cause of many house fires fox news
contributor cat tim
john welcome to the show you look
fabulous you don't age well you better
get your glasses checked
i'm 76 i'm not middle-aged i'm not going
to be 152.
what maybe i would you just i always
maybe i don't know you just i it's also
your perilous just yeah and old chickens
make good soup
are you as worried about the children
you know i care about children as you
can see too yeah i was in the alvin the
chipmunk movie you forget
here's how i want to be a teacher yes
and i've tried to go in and i thought
what i'd do is the first day i'd give
him all ridlen and then no matter what
their race i'd make them write any bonux
on the class once i will talk in class
and then i guess i'd be controversial
and introduce a don't say straight
campaign
or they can't talk about plumbers crack
missionary position or line dancing or
the state of florida
until they can make up their own mind
exactly you never know i'm with you on
that i don't think we should talk about
any of that stuff but then again you
know i just prefer children not to be
taught at all just be kept on an island
well i think
you know kids to me because i was in the
album the chipmunk movie i'm in an
airport and a child will come over and
look up and say pick me up i thought
they'll pick you up look at me i look
like chester the molester
pick you up
or a parent saying like where's my kid
in john waters lap
not good even though even you know
you're a threat which is good john
so kennedy i wasn't going to come to you
because i don't think you have any
strong feelings about this topic
i just if if they close new york city
schools again i'm going to pick it not
just my daughter's schools but literally
every schools every every school in new
york city i'm going gonna get cat and
i'm gonna get beggin and i'm gonna get
some white claws and some giant signs
and some big fat markers and we are
going to protest everything and this is
what parents have been saying the entire
time since april of 2020. we've been
like when are you gonna get kids back in
school this isn't good those of us who
could see our kids having a hard time it
wasn't just that they weren't learning
it was that they were being mentally
tortured by the pandemic and you know on
top of that they're being propagandized
that they're horribly racist people but
then somehow they are the cause of the
deaths of people in their family
therefore they have to either extricate
themselves from school or mask
themselves completely or they're going
to kill grandma and it's no surprise
that math was the thing that that
where you saw the greatest learning
losses and i don't know how you make
that up i don't know what's going to
happen to these kids once they get into
college because i don't know if colleges
are going to have the patience to work
them back into an academic environment
it's it's bad news for at least four
years of learning for kids that's a
that's the thing it's like can they
dagan is there any way to actually fix
this or remedy this like some kind of
post i don't know
like make them go to school year round
oh yes
that's cruel and unusual
or bad school yeah school is a prison
isn't it well when i went to school they
discouraged every interest i have
because they didn't say i want to be the
puke king and they wouldn't laugh
with the sawdust
they come out with the sawdust and put
it on the or vauban do you know what
that is that's a product that you throw
to clean up puke in the carnival the
carnivals it's called vauban
i'm gonna buy stock in that
i
children will recover because school is
awful i hated school i i'm a weirdo i
wanted to be at home playing with
daddy's chainsaws yeah and gi joe with
my fake pinecone hand grenades that i
would throw at my brother but going to
school was important because i'm a
weirdo i learned to be a functional
weirdo that could exist in the outside
world right like i learned to keep my
mouth shut so i wouldn't get popped in
the in the face but i did learn like a
wicked eye roll so i could communicate
with my eyes or i learned i learned how
to fight in case you have to get in a
fight always go for the ears really and
i
and i learned that um
don't like
i i learned that you shouldn't pick your
nose in public because most people find
that yes
most not all
i learned about trashy girls one girl in
the school she had her hair perfect in
the front and the back was a rat's nest
and she turned around she said who cares
what they think but i'm leaving the room
and i only care what they think when i
walk in
and i thought wow that person's name is
judge janine
i'm gonna say it was cat
cat another uh uh wonderful
turn as uh dirtbag dev thank you yes yes
thank you john i just want to say i
think you're really on to something they
put me on ritalin when i was five and i
turned out great
it's just like diet pills it works
uh i just i mean welcome to the party to
the new york times i guess like you said
we've been talking about this uh and
it's not just all these studies that
have been coming out it's you know
teachers unions did this because they
didn't want to go to work and i think i
said this months or maybe a year ago
that i knew how bad it was
you know teachers had to be doing
something really bad to get us to start
saying bad things about teachers
no that's true like
can you even imagine that a few years
ago where we were saying bats like you
couldn't say bad stuff about teachers
because teachers were were selfless
amazing heroes right but this is insane
and we all knew this and again the
headlines like new research it's like
okay this is maybe the better word to be
latest research in the long line of lots
of other research showing that this
really hurt kids and there was you know
no real benefit in terms of
stopping the spread of kovacs i still
think that uh um at home learning like i
always say the peloton model having
charismatic celebrity teachers on it
like a on a little machine to sit the
kid there and then nationalize it but
that was that was actually you said that
on the five and that was one of the best
ideas that i had heard because what they
did it allowed kids to turn off their
cameras so they didn't even have to show
up and it wasn't just the teachers it
was the teachers unions that were
fighting out of teachers only teach
three hours a day and utla the president
of utla said there was no learning law
so all of the teachers unions should be
completely disbanded oh there you go a
family member of mine was getting
youtube videos that was part of the at
home um remote learning was watch some
youtube videos a couple of hours a week
that's what i do yeah well
i zoom i'm always no picture i'm not
doing hair and makeup for a phone call
zoom looks so ugly how people have sex
on zoom i don't care
you really look ugly on zoom that camera
angle looking up oh
that's jeffrey toobin yeah yes
then you have to disinfect the keyboard
and yeah
where are we all right up next the media
is working overtime smearing musk with
racist slime hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else